SOLUTION.FIERE IS "
N SACKHEATERD NG
IT DIDN'T LAST LONG.
THAT DOESN'T BODE WELL FORHE
SEUNMO TRED F A NEIN
NETANYAHU.
ITION IN MODERLISING PARTH NETAN
ISRAELI ABARS.
COULD SUCH A STAY
TOGETHER.
IT IS POSSIBLE BEE
TOANUS DISLIKEBI
AHU ISND
EEES
, PRUTY HIS
OWND
GENERAL.
ELEMENTS OIN ITH HLLIED BI BROK
N THE COALITION ISJUST NOT STR
ERE LATEST ELECTIONS TUTH
OF THE FAR RIGFUAM
MORE STRONGLY
THEN
EVER BEFORE.
THERE IS AWITH THE
20IONS IN THE UNED
ILEPRESENTED APUAFTER MOSTSIDEN
E DID NOT
REPRESENDI
TRUMPI
TH PTYS INPRPOLITICO SAID IT WDE
DOLLARS LIBERALS SPENT TSLATURE,
FLINA AN
TEXAS, THOIES REMA  UNDERS E
SIDED ADVANTAGE IN REDISTRICTING
WHICH WILL HELP THDELISTBADLY A
POWER BUT THE MOMENT HAVE NOT FH
BEATINGS. MAE RSMACRON SEEMS TOA
DOWN TO 41 PERCENT ANDIS
THN.D THFAR RIGHNDN IN
IMPORTANT THAT THE LEFT
TOO MANY IN IT BELD IS QUEIO
,
E S MA
DITH.
BUT HOW DO YOU T M
PRESENT THE NEW ITIES OF POLITI
CLASS TH ISL
CONSHAMAE IN TD PARTOF  SO
TAKE A AGAINST BUST DON'T TRUST
YOU P PEOPLE AND SHOOUT TO WORWR
HO TIONS WILL UDER THAN THEIBINT
'S NOT TALKING ABOUT DR. SEUSS
BOOKS OR THE GOLDE'S
GENERALLY STEE CLEAR OF THE
PISODES  T CULTURE. PRGRATIOOWI
TRIGGWHEN ASKEDESABOUT BIDEN'0
REMARKED THATYTHAT HE
WA NOTY LOUNGE
POLI MNG UA
MANYLARGE  ARROGANY T ROLT.HI
HERALEFT IS BASKING INTSRECE FRO
BU